like what who are you I don't know I
just I think maybe because my mindset is
always spiritual first like I come from
a very spiritual perspective of things
so I just feel like so if I was to say
I'm damaged okay I can say I'm damaged
but then I'm that's not gonna be my
story because I don't want that to it
will be your story it will be a part of
this song
I don't want it to be the thing that I'm
like oh I'm damaged so therefore I can't
do you know what I mean I don't think
you can't it's just like like this is
part of your CV so when you give someone
your CV and it's like oh toxic
relationship I was so toxic I had to cut
all my friends off for six months
they're like okay red flag okay maybe
like this is this girl's maybe a 10. now
she's an eight now she's a seven now
she's a six whatever it is and so it's
like that's what I'm saying once you go
through [ __ ] you put yourself on sale
and that's at least honest go ahead then
I was thinking like when you broke up
you consider that break up as a failure
like a personal failure it is and yeah
but at the same time I truly believe
that I learn with failure you can learn
a lesson so I can improve myself with
the breakup yes I will be damaged I'll
go to the next relationship with a wool
baggage and they're still going to be
damaged but at the same time if I take
the lesson I can learn from that yeah so
you can improve yourself in a way that's
valuable to women but not to men there's
nothing after a toxic relationship is
going to make you better because you've
had sex with more people
you've been in more talk you probably
have more toxic habits from it and
you're older so the things that men
value you're you're offering nothing
maybe to you it might be better but
that's like a woman's point of view
because we prefer men with experience
and lived experience because then they
know how to deal better with women
because we're all crazy
so so you it's like and that's common
you're not like the only one that's come
on the show and you know said that but
it's it's like it's a very much a
woman's point of view is and where man
is just like oh that's baggage
yeah it's quite clear as well that like
you if you talk about if you if you
mention something like you know the
healing thing and it's a toxic guy to me
all that says is that guy had an impact
on you in it like no matter how she's
trying to act like yeah you know I've
heard them different now I'm thinking
yeah yo yeah my 50 years my death but
she's gonna be like yeah but I just want
to talk to him one more time
that's what that means still I think
this idea of you can definitely
heal
um and retain you know a lot of your
value but I think you have to have the
right mindset and today people are so
self-obsessed that they they take it
into the more the ego driven bit so
every time they're healed they're like
I'm better I'm better now I'm better I
deserve more and it's like no you're not
in fact you know you deserve laughs
instead of saying I'm better maybe it
should be I'm gonna do better no not I'm
better because you're right in what
you're saying once you're damaged you
are damaged that's not gonna go anywhere
you can paint it in whatever color you
want you can make it pretty and all the
rest of it once you've had a bad
experience that is going to be then it
will go with you
but then what comes in is who you meet
how that person decides to deal with you
yeah
she said I mean you can meet someone
that might be a bit sensitive towards
you you might meet someone that isn't
sensitive
that makes a difference can I just add
to you said something about how on the
spiritual side like you're allowed to
kind of repent I don't whoa no I don't
know is that what you meant no because
repentance is basically saying okay I'm
now absolved from all my sins okay cool
but I I understand the whole religious
aspect but my mind's more like spiritual
and you said you can kind of cleanse
like yeah you can cleanse so and so my
point would be for the cleansing bit
like you still have mileage on the clock
yeah you know what I mean yeah so
whether you've cleansed or not these
things have happened but does the
mileage sit in you though yeah yeah yeah
yeah
if your if your situation put you to a
mileage of sixty thousand whether you
cleanse or not you're still at sixty
thousand maybe you're not trying to get
any more but like you you still at 60
000 you don't go back you can't reset
the meter on your car I don't know I
think I just have this thing about the
mind like if you can if you program the
minds to but I get what you're saying
it's that's a woman's point of view no
because because women women like a guy
that's had a past and like been through
some [ __ ] and now he's come out better
because men have to create their value
where women are born with value
so yeah so you're you're born you're
given the golden ticket at 18. even even
now you like you guys are early 30s
mid-20s like life is hard for men they
grow up being ignored most of their life
and so whereas women we're given
attention like what when's the first
time yeah when's the first time you had
a guy hit on you 13 14 15 something yeah
yeah yeah and and so we don't even
realize how hard the world is for men
and how easy it is for us where we can
like spout nonsense and nobody says
anything that's true and we could like
use all these words and I it like I had
to listen a lot to men before I
understood what they were talking about
but I'm like yeah we talk a lot of
nothing do you know what it is I just
put like the disconnect is like
I feel like some of you are establishing
what makes you a better person whereas
she's talking about what makes you a
better partner you know I mean so it's
like a better person doesn't necessarily
make you a better partner okay now so
that makes so much sense actually I
think it's both actually because I think
a lot of the time
yeah I already made this point right
about what what people tend to be think
think of as making themselves a better
person it's just more a more ego driven
yeah I think the sign that someone's
healed and someone's overcome something
is that it becomes insignificant to them
you know someone came out said I'm a
piece I'm a piece of a piece I know
you're definitely not a piece yeah yeah
you could just be it exactly
if that trauma was if you were over that
trauma that wouldn't be a key narrative
in your life you know it's just
something that doesn't sometimes need to
be mentioned yeah like I looked up
um what are feminine traits nurturing
soft caring playful empathetic
compassionate vulnerable so when we're
talking about healing like all the
things you guys listed none of them got
you to that like tastes like getting rid
of people for six months doesn't make
you more nurturing soft caring playful
empathetic going on a trip doesn't make
you more nurturing soft caring playful
or pathetic compassionate and vulnerable
yeah do the Opposites yeah it does the
opposite
in addition to no relationship but
that's exactly my point
let's say you feel more confident yeah
but it's to a point where like you're
now shutting like you're more masculine
yeah that's made you a more confident
and better person in yourself but as a
partner you might not be looking for
that woman who's too loud all that too
in his face it's again because we become
the man we want to marry because we like
confident men they don't their guys are
into confident women they're into shy
women that are like reserves
in any Kingdom
doesn't mean you're better I think it
says the latter because when I go
through spiritual experiences Etc I
become way more tolerant because now
it's less about me and it's more about
like I see why you did that I see I
understand this so I can have you this
better so we don't have to argue we have
to fight I get it
um so if you come out of a so-called
spiritual experience and you're actually
less tolerant of everyone around you
that gives that's again lends more
Credence to the idea of that it's more
of a narcissistic ritual it's more like
but that wasn't what I was talking about
the spiritual the cutting off thing had
nothing to do with spirituality at all
it was more about
cleansed like dealing with the noise
that was in my head it had nothing to do
with like spiritual stuff that was for
me but the whole the whole spiritual
thing is I think you know often serve as
a really good way to not be accountable
because spiritualism is relative like
you could make a lot of cases and say
you know listen to Jada Pinkett Smith
right she can validate hanging with
August all day yeah
okay she might not be a good example but
they're common and so this is this is
common whenever I hear to girls talk
about like spiritual experiences I'm
like just say you're three or four no
I just and I'm not I don't know you so I
I'm not saying you are I'm just saying
this is I've talked to so many people in
the last six months that these are like
patterns yeah like people that I know
that are spiritual I don't know tons but
they all seem to have some sort of level
head and I know what you mean by you're
saying that people could just say oh
well I'm spiritual and they can push
that onto that but there are there are
people sorry there are people who are
not like that there are people I get
what you're saying about being tolerable
and more tolerant but sometimes that
comes with stepping away from the noise
realizing okay what can I do what am I
sure of what can I give what can I take
back what can I keep from us what can I
give it's not just about ego but I get
what you're saying as well it's a give
and take it's a balance of both
if that makes any sense you look very
confused
I understood what you said okay
I can see a butt
um yeah I understand that but to me it
just sounded like I need to be right it
kind of It kind of just sounded like
um
you know trying to get out the fact that
spiritual practice breeds tolerance and
love more so than anything else and it
minimizes self and so if that
understanding if you say talk about that
story I hate to be personal to me most
of the key points of that that your
story or your spiritual journey or
healing one it didn't make you more
loving it didn't make you you just talk
about yourself a lot you said you know
me me you know that kind of thing it
didn't make you more tolerant
that other experience was something else
but I think spiritual connects to
everything like we have a pattern and
you can see it in our life so your
healing Journey isn't disassociated from
that action whether it was before or
after you're saying everything is
interconnected it's interconnected and
so you know yes you need you need time
alone but
um cutting people off again it even
sounds like a bit of a plan to focus on
the right things basically yeah it even
sounds like a power play like you never
hear someone appear saying I caught
people off what do you think I meant by
cutting people off I for me it was just
them not having access or availability
every single day throughout the day
sorry but when you when you hear that
that doesn't sound feminine nurturing or
soft but I am feminine nurturing I don't
think well you don't I'm saying you
don't come across that way because of
the words that you say but that's
because I'm able to articulate I'm I'm
Impressions so and I don't think it's a
bad thing for me to say I'm intelligent
but if I'm in a man's presence or if I'm
with someone who I'm romantically
connected with my my aura and how I I am
is very different so if we asked your
access would they agree yeah okay and
they what my ex watches this show so
hopefully he's watching any comments
[Music]
okay it's kind of like if a man said I'm
super masculine but only when I'm around
women but so so so like that's like if a
guy said like it sounds like crazy
because like if a guy if a guy comes in
he acts super like feminine right and
he's like hey like hey girls then he's
like look it I am super masculine but
only when I'm around Victoria's Secret
models I get what you're saying but I'm
in a situation right now where I have to
think and I have to articulate myself so
therefore maybe do you know what maybe
that's my Alpha side I don't know maybe
that is my Alpha side I've run a
business so I have that Alpha streak but
at the same time I've been with men who
are quite Alpha and they're like they've
pointed certain things out to me so I've
learned not only through what I've seen
at home with my mom and my dad but I've
also learned through those men and
through my own journey to be more
feminine so I I'll be about loving
energy it's about patience it's about
it's about all these kind of compromise
and everything you say seems to be more
around
you know you you kind of you know
realizing power in some way so
you know you say you're intelligent and
you're you've had a business and you've
caught people off and no but you're
allowed listing your aura is like
different in other people it's all a lot
of affirmations and words you you tend
to you you know what to say but feminine
femininity isn't like I guess yeah it's
a way of being yeah like it's loving it
like you can tell you can tell when
someone's feminine but no one can tell
me they're feminine that doesn't mean
anything for everyone who knows me who
experiences me will tell you otherwise
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on
his
arm
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible